hey what's up guys and welcome to
Network chat programming I am your host
the Cherno and yeah I'm not gonna do
that again anyway so my name is Jonah
and welcome to episode 2 of network chat
programming so that's what I've called
the series and yeah that's man anyway
let's get back into this so basically if
we check out what we did last time we
basically just created a window if we
hit design here on our window builder
then you will see what our forum
currently looks like and that's what it
looks like ok so the idea of this login
window is just to give people a way to
first of all specify a server to connect
to and also to actually specify a name
for them to take on so that when
multiple clients because the court we
can have multiple clients with us to say
60 people connected oh yes best idea but
once this is finished you guys are going
to download moral gonna have like
freaking chat party yeah but anyway the
point is if we get like 60 people
connecting to this or something we can't
all have them the same right you gotta
have different names ok and now while we
probably won't do to any validation we
can we might do that if you guys really
want us to do that so that people only
have unique name so in other words if I
can act as the channel or as churna
excuse me if I can act as the channel
will turn or whatever and someone else
types the exact same name and tries to
connect the server might reject him and
be like nah that's been taken you can't
do that we might do that that might be
an advanced feature if you guys request
that but the point is we want to we want
people to be able to specify a name a
server address and a port for the for
the UM client to connect to so that's
what this login thing is all about so
let's make it look like a login window
so I think honestly I'm just going to
resize it a bit so best thing that
window buildup this is definitely the
best thing about when I build it but the
point is you can actually use these um
things here to actually resize your
window so let's do that and maybe 360 I
don't know I'm I'm just kind of I don't
know there's all good let's just take a
look at that so if we hit ctrl s or
command s + Mac at the debug button I
think that's pretty yeah that's pretty
good
I like that so that the window size is
300 by 380 ok that's the size of that
window now the next thing that you
should do probably is
actually let's specify a title first so
if we just click on the window here
we'll get a bunch of properties pop up
here you can actually specify a title
here and again you can do this with code
just by set title or frame dulcet title
if you're not extending jframe I don't
think okay we are sending gen for him so
yeah literally set title but we can do
it through here as well so here's a
title thing we'll call this Cherno chat
normal school is login actually just
login there it is so again that'll
updated and if we go back to source
you'll see that we actually have set
title login okay that's pretty awesome
it does it for you um and again
obviously it's not really necessary for
stuff like this but when we get into
stuff like positioning buttons and
making text fields and that stuff is
just that stuff is ludicrous if we do it
um by code and it's it's not something
because obviously the frame isn't being
updated every second you can't really
hot WAP it you can't really live debug
it so it gets to be a pain but what we
have to do here is actually specify what
I like to do well what you should do is
specify type of layout so there are so
many layouts here that you can choose
from we're going to be using two okay
not for this login frame we're going to
be using one for this login window and
one for the actual um one for the actual
client so the one that will actually use
for this login window will be absolute
layout which means that we can actually
um we specify the exact location of each
component and the reason we're going to
do that is because this is not going to
be resizable so let's click on the
window and he recessive sizable let's
just uncheck that okay so now we cannot
resize this window and we don't want it
because it's just a login window we
don't know we don't need to resize it we
will be able to resize the actual client
because of course I expect people might
want to make it smaller make it big in
like maximize make it fullscreen or
whatever and that's just a nice feature
to have so yeah we will have to use a
different layout for that but for this
since this is non resizable we might as
well use an absolute layout in fact my
recommendation is if you are not going
to resize a window use the absolute
layout at all time so just click on it
right over here on the layouts and click
on to login so now we've got an absolute
layout okay
and actually notice here that it set um
set layout null
okay so null is an absolute layout
because we don't have any specifically
out
so I just had command shift or control
shift on Windows to organize my inputs
together to the bottle bottle out and
stuff that we don't use umm but yeah so
pretty now we're pretty much ready to
actually start making buttons so the
first thing I think I want to do right
now is just make probably feels okay so
I might make a I'll scroll down to
components here and we'll see it
something called a jtextfield grab that
and let's put that and you'll see that
it actually appears quite long enough
some reason but um let's sit shhh maybe
like I don't make it too big what you
can actually do is if we place it right
now you can actually let's give it a
name first of all um people just call it
a name okay so and then what you won't
have to go on the text here and delete
name the reason I type name in so that
the variable name would be text name so
they've actually called it something but
we can actually do now is you can click
on it and then what you can do is you
can actually align it pretty much so we
can align it vertically by hitting this
button and you can see it centers it and
we can Center it vertically if we want
as well but this centers at horizontal
ease button here so you don't have to
you know make sure it's completely right
I might just make it a bit whoops yep
just a bit bigger here so that's really
good I think that looks pretty good
maybe that's a bit too big
make it 165 I should be good that's for
your name okay and let's also make a um
a jlabel over here just to people know
they should type their name here and I'm
calling it okay and we'll Center that as
well there you go okay let's make it a
bit smaller um you might have to
experiment with the sizes of these
things because Mac text I believe is a
bit larger than Windows in pub why you
might have to make sure that is portable
whatever but um if we run this now you
can see that what we've got here is a
name and we can type in like China or oh
my god it comes for my name or yarn or
whatever um Bob there's no one called
Bob shout out to you and you can see
what color side the data so yeah that's
what we get right now okay and as you
can see it's really easy using this um
this thing here this windowbuilder thing
to actually do this stuff like this it's
done all of this code now for us which
couldn't have done like without it well
we could of obviously but what I mean is
there would be it would have been so
much harder so one thing that I don't
like the window builder does
automatically is actually it is you can
say final launch is it in the top left
right and that's not like that's not too
cool I like it too for example for this
I want it to be centered so let's do
that
okay let's actually modify set bounce we
know that the width is 300 and the
height is 380 so let's um
get rid of that and let's manually set
the size set size to 300 by 380 and then
we'll just set the location relative to
no so just like we did with pretty much
again our game programming stuff and now
if we launch it what you'll see is it's
in the center okay so that's one thing
that you can do that's just again an
ascetical thing you don't have to do
that but what happens is if you do
actually resize it again it's going to
reset based for this it probably won't
remove our set size and set location but
it will add the set bounds so don't
don't do that only do this little thing
once it is um once it is once you
finalize your size all right anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed episode 2 that has
been episode 2 next time we'll take a
look at actually creating a button and
the rest of our text fields I'm gonna
have to keep this episode short for
multiple reasons primarily the fact that
I have a bit of a lack of bandwidth and
processing power so it's a lot easier
for me to keep from shorter but um
hopefully we can get them pretty
frequently so yeah anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed this episode and I'll see
you guys next time bye
you